hey everybody thanks for being here
thanks for watching and listening you'll
have to excuse me for showing my Ravens
pride today because it is the draft the
draft is ongoing and it's so stupid that
people actually sit there and watch a
draft so you're just watching a guy over
and over again walk up to a podium and
say a name and then that for just hours
but I'm one of those stupid people that
watches it it's I can't defend it but I
do and it also shows why no matter what
anyone says but oh the NFL's falling off
and so some football or a basketball or
baseball or hockey is gonna take over no
the NFL still football still the number
one sport in America and if you want
evidence of that just look at the fact
that millions of people millions of
people like myself will sit there and
watch a draft anyway so I thought I'd
like to do kind of a mailbag thing today
answering answering something from one
of the many emails that I did throughout
the week and I had that in mind this
week and I was looking through my email
to see if there's anything if anyone
raised kind of an issue that'd be
interesting for a video and I and I and
I found one email that that I'd like to
try to address although I am a little
bit hesitant because it's a very serious
issue and I you know I want to make sure
that I'm approaching this the right way
and saying the right things so if
somebody emailed me with a distressing
problem couple days ago hee hee
although this is not the you know I've
heard I've heard this from plenty of
other people this kind of thing which is
what made me think well this would be a
good one to address he said that he's
been getting more absorbed in his faith
recently getting more invested into his
faith he's reading scripture more he's
going to church he's praying he's doing
all these things he'd never really done
before although he'd always always been
Christian but he never really been
actively Christian until recently which
is great you know yet he said he's also
been experiencing doubt to a degree that
he never experienced it
for sometimes just questioning I mean
how can this be real how how could that
have happened how could Jesus be real I
mean what is what does that even this
mean how how is this possible is that
you know those kinds of doubts he
doesn't want to question them he doesn't
invite the questions in but they're just
there in his head and and so he's
troubled by it and he wanted to know if
I had any advice well before I say
anything else I just want to add my
usual disclaimer that I'm not an expert
on this issue or on any issue so if
anyone is really going through a
spiritual crisis you should certainly
speak to your pastor or priest or
spiritual director somebody like that I
can only only share just a few thoughts
I don't know if they'll be useful or not
hopefully they are so let me do that
okay so first of all we should establish
that doubts are normal okay we all we
all have them it's a normal thing it may
be kind of a taboo subject in Christian
circles to talk about because we're all
supposed to pretend that we'd never have
them but what everyone does
it doesn't mean and I want to talk I'm
gonna explain this more as we go on a
little bit more towards the end but just
because a doubt enters your head doesn't
mean that you don't have faith so you
can have faith yet be experiencing that
as well
we're human after all we so this is
going to happen even the people who knew
Jesus and who saw him performing
miracles which which you know we we have
not we read about the miracles but in in
Scripture but we haven't actually seen
them for ourselves even those people had
doubts John the Baptist who according to
Jesus was the greatest man ever the
greatest mortal man ever born according
to Jesus was John the Baptist and even
he appeared to have doubts and not only
doubts but he had the doubts after
witnessing God speak from the heavens
after Jesus was baptized announcing this
is my son so John the Baptist heard a
voice from the heavens declaring Jesus
is my son and yet a little while after
that he's in prison because he stood up
to the sexual immorality of Herod Herod
threw him in prison he's languishing in
prison and he sends his followers out to
find Jesus and ask Jesus are you the one
are you the Messiah or should we look
for another and Jesus's response to that
is I think really interesting Jesus says
okay go tell go tell John the go tell
them what you've seen the blind can see
the lame can walk the dead have been
raised and he says blessed are those who
are not scandalized in me and what Jesus
means by that he says not scandalized in
me meaning blessed are the people who
who yeah I may not be acting the way you
thought the Messiah was going to act
this may not be playing out the way you
thought it would but blessed are the
people who just humble themselves before
that truth and accept what's actually
happening rather than being you know
kind of offended or outraged or taken
aback by the fact that I don't fit into
this box that you had you know that
you've this kind of fictional box of
what you think a messiah is supposed to
be so he said so he sends his he sends
them back to tell John the Baptist that
so that's John the Baptist appearing to
have doubts now I've heard some
Christians and some theologians have
have argued that you could interpret
that passage a little bit differently
and John sent his followers to Jesus to
ask that question
he sent them for for their own sake so
that they would know John already knew
he didn't question it but he sent him
for their sake that's a very generous
interpretation for John the Baptist's
sake but I don't see that in the
scripture there's no real evidence of
that all we see is John asking this
question so it would really appear that
he himself had doubts so that's the
first thing it's natural for our egos
our egos are going to rub
Bell against this thing this truth that
is so beyond our capacity for
comprehension that's natural second it's
not actually surprising although it
seems surprising it seems
counterintuitive it's not actually
surprising that somebody would have
doubts that actually intensify for a
season as they delve deeper into their
faith and but for two for two reasons
number one because Satan is going to see
that you're drawing nearer to God he's
gonna see that you're getting all
Christian on him and he's not gonna like
that so he's gonna pull out all the
stops to sabotage you sabotage you but
but for another I think the Bible is is
much easier and more palatable and much
easier to ingest when we see it only in
these little soundbites these little
slogans these little chunks these little
just inspirational tweets or whatever
when that's all that we've seen of the
Bible just the things that are kind of
out there in the culture in the book in
our in our vocabulary in our language
and that's all we see of the Bible it's
much easier for us to wrap our heads
around but when we really study it and
we read it seriously and we take it
seriously and we read it in context and
we read it from you know the entire
context of it page cover to cover type
of thing then we can we I think we begin
to appreciate not only the scriptures
richness and beauty but also its
complexity and its challenges and its
mysteries and even its apparent
contradictions just as one example if
you've never really read if you've never
really read the Gospels all you've done
is you've just skimmed we've seen the
chunks then you probably think you've
got it pretty nailed on you've got the
the story of the resurrection in your
head you think you've got it nailed down
you basically understand that the women
go to the tomb and then there's an angel
and then they go back and you think
you've got all the you think you've
basically yeah you understand that but
then you go and you read all the gospel
accounts and you start to see you now
wait a second what's going on here
because there appear to be several
different stories that all contradict
and now you're more can for you more
you're more confused now than you were
before you even read it then it takes an
even closer look to see how okay all
these things really do line up when we
consider the different perspectives and
the different ways that the gospel
writers are trying to tell the story the
different things that they're focusing
on and then it all kind of starts to
line up so the point is when we start to
read the Bible we see that it's not as
simple as we thought
based on our skimming of it and this
realization is fascinating and it's
invigorating and and all of that but
there's also a certain anxiety that
comes with it and that's normal and we
shouldn't panic over that I think two
thoughts occur to anyone who actually
reads the Gospels carefully number one
there is so much here that is mysterious
and and impossible to understand number
two nobody wouldn't make up a story like
this even the hardest parts that the
parts that seem to make the least amount
of sense they actually only further
approve the authenticity of the gospel
because nobody would make that up
nobody if somebody was inventing the
story they wouldn't put that in there
they wouldn't write it like that that's
not the way it would be so you know in
the past I have felt myself challenged
by the what I would call kind of the the
the spareness of Scripture its its lack
of drama its lack of the kind of details
that you would expect it to have it's
it's you know the way that especially in
the Gospels things aren't really fleshed
out the way you might think they will be
so you've got this whole gap in Christ's
life between infancy and his public
ministry with
this one random brief scene in the
middle where he gets separated from his
parents his parents come back and find
him in the temple but there's just that
and then and then but but between but
besides that it's just he's a baby and
then his public ministry and you think
well why you know what's going on why
didn't you tell why didn't you give us a
few more what happened in between that
time why aren't you telling us that and
then Christ enters into his public
ministry and all of these incredible
things are happening but the gospel for
the most part just relays these things
in a really matter-of-fact way it never
dwells on anything for very long so he
multiplies loaves he walks on water he
heals the blind he raises the dead he
cast out demons he's doing all of this
but there's so little drama in the way
these incidents are told to us these
incidents themselves are extremely
dramatic of course and beautiful but but
the way the gospel tells it is it just
okay that happened and then they just
move on to the next thing they don't
spend pages and pages telling us how
people reacted to the fact that Jesus
raised Lazarus from the dead they're
just moving on really quickly and then
Jesus is arrested and here we are at the
climax of the story right if somebody
was if this was being written by a
novelist or screenwriter or something
this is the climax we have Jesus
arrested by his enemies God incarnate
arrested standing trial and here's his
chance to deliver one last great
monologue or speech right in front of
his enemies while they're trying to trap
him and he can kind of stand up there
with everyone looking at him but what
happens that's the way it would go if
somebody was making up this story they
wouldn't be able to resist this
opportunity for this climactic scene but
that's not what happens he just he just
remains silent for the most part Jesus
throughout his entire passion he really
says very little and what he does say
and how he does react it's very
understated he slapped across the face
by some servant and he said
you know what what have I done I haven't
done anything wrong if I haven't done
anything wrong why are you hitting me I
mean that's his response this
opportunity for drama is seemingly
wasted and and then he goes off and he
dies and then he comes back from the
dead and okay here we go
now's another chance for some great
scenes again this was being written by
somebody somebody telling a story making
up a story and they've got and they've
got their God they invented coming back
from the dead okay what's he gonna do
he's gonna go to the Pharisees and he's
gonna say see I told you so and there's
gonna be seen with the Pharisees that
are just are you know just collapse and
shock and maybe he gives another Sermon
on the Mount kind of a sequel I mean
he'd do something write something but no
he he mostly just eats fish with his
apostles the very little happens and
even when he and then and then and then
of course he ascends into heaven which
is a another scene which you would
expect a lot of drama but that's not the
way that's not the way scripture tells
it you know he the scripture this this
is what scripture tells gee now this is
Jesus Christ ascending into heaven
and he said and it says when he had said
this as they were looking on he was
lifted up and a cloud took him from
their sight that's it but that's the
entire story of him ascending into
heaven there's no more aren't any more
sentences fleshing out what that looked
like and there were you know just
nothing it's just he ascended into
heaven and then that's it and then
immediately we're told to so they're
looking up and there's in there and
they're in shock that Jesus just
ascended into heaven and then he's gone
and and then there are two men in white
robes two angels that appear and say
what are you guys looking at okay now
let's get to work guys come on stop
dwelling on it let's get to work
on a very shallow level you see that and
you say now that's not what would
actually happen what are you talking
about I mean there'd be a lot more to it
right but then you realize no this is
this is this is the way that it's told
if it's just true the Gospel writers are
just telling us what happened that's all
they're not they're not fiction writers
they're just telling you they're
reporting the facts and the facts are
the facts Jesus because he is true he is
real he confounds his critics who
subverts expectations he doesn't fit
into any kind of box he's not doing what
you would think he would do he's not
doing the things that anyone would ever
predict he's just he's real this is just
what was and still is and that's all and
that's the way that it's relayed in the
Bible and I think when you really read
the Bible after a while you begin to
appreciate that fact third thing about
doubt we are mortal beings and we have
an extremely finite capacity for
understanding we will never be able to
fully comprehend the mysteries of God
don't listen to anyone who says they
have it all figured out because they
don't and anyone who claims to is a
charlatan and a false prophet and we
should steer very clear of them but also
don't listen to anyone who says well
there shouldn't be any mysteries in your
faith that's a cop-out what do you mean
it's a mystery that's a cop I need you
to explain the Trinity three persons in
one explain that three persons in one
but you're saying it's monotheistic not
polytheistic explain that how's that
possible you need to explain it exactly
you can't just say mystery don't listen
to that either because no matter what we
believe all of us myths must submit
ourselves to the mysteries of life
we all have to deal with the fact that
so much of life is mysterious and that
goes for atheists too and atheists
cannot say how we came into being you
can't say how human beings gained
consciousness he can't say where love
and joy and despair and morality
originate he can't tell you how a
trillion in possibilities all came
together so that you and I could come
into existence you can't explain how
inanimate matter became animate he can't
explain chaos and how that became order
and how unconscious became consciousness
he can't say what the universe is or why
it exists or why we exist or how he just
has faith he has to have faith
he has his explanation that he cannot
prove and he just has faith it's not
like nobody has ever observed or seen or
demonstrated how in animate material
could become sentient that's never been
that's never but no one has ever
observed that in fact we know
scientifically it's impossible there
might be a lot of science fiction about
oh maybe one day we'll create a robot
that's sentient and has like a human
conscious no no that's never going to
happen
it's impossible you cannot build
something with metal and you know wiring
that will become sentient you can't do
that because that's sentience is not a
physical thing you can't create it at a
physical matter yet we know somehow
sentience did come into being we all
know that we're sentient so atheists
have their explanation that is based
entirely in faith they cannot
demonstrate it it is not scientific and
their explanation is physically
scientifically impossible yet they
believe it
but there's a difference in our faith
okay
the secular world has a faith based on
pride it cannot answer very many
questions or explain very many things or
describe how any of this came into being
but it assumes based on arrogance and
ego that it cannot be due to a force
greater than themselves so it looks at
the world and it says surely there
cannot be a Power greater than myself
so however this stuff came into being it
must not have anything to do with any
power that transcends myself but the
religious person looks at the world and
says surely there must be a Power
greater than myself I have so little
control over anything in my life I
understand so little yet here I am and
here is everyone and here's the world
here's civilization here's the ocean
here are mountains here are animals and
in the human brain and a billion
fantastic and incomprehensible things I
can see the design I can see that I'm a
part of it but I know I didn't make it
somebody must have religious faith grows
from humility and this is what you know
the Atheist idea that they desperately
cling to that somehow even though it's
impossible dust somehow through some
accidental process became over time
human consciousness they cling to that
because they are desperate to still at
the end of the day they themselves still
want to be top dog in the universe they
cannot cede that place to anyone
religious faith grows from humility and
that's why I think we first have to have
faith in God before we can understand
anything about him so it goes faith
first then under
standing well we try to do a lot of a
lot of the time this is a mistake that
people have been making since the time
of Christ is where you try to flip that
around and you say well let me
understand first and then I'll have
faith make me understand and then fine
I'll have faith but first of all that's
not faith if you just know you have full
comprehension somehow of the omnipotent
God and you're able somehow to wrap your
head around all of that well then
there's no faith involved faith faith is
to submit yourself to this thing that is
greater than yourself and that you
cannot fully understand but if we have
faith and we kneel before God then over
time he will give us more and more
understanding we'll never have perfect
understanding we'll never have a
complete understanding but we'll have
more and more understanding over time
and it gives us that understanding just
because you know because we have opened
ourselves to it we humble ourselves
before the mystery of God we accept with
submission and obedience the things we
don't know and can never know or
understand with faith and then over time
more more understanding grows but it's
not an understanding the reason that God
gives us understanding in that case and
not before is because when we demand
understanding before faith then it's
kind of like blackmail to God we're
saying oh you want me to believe well
then you better you know hey you got to
pony up and show me some miracles or
something that's not the right attitude
but he gives us understanding after
faith because he knows that with that
understanding it's not like something
that we're demanding so that will
believe in him but just so that the more
that we understand the more that we can
just be in awe of the beauty and wonder
of God
so we always have to recognize the
origin of doubt which is pride it's that
part of our brain that says this is
challenging this is difficult this BIA
this is beyond my power of understanding
so therefore it can't be true
now the Atheist gives in completely to
this part of his brain the Christian
fights against it by the grace of God so
I think that's the answer to doubt don't
try to reason your way out of it don't
argue with yourself
don't go researching the historical
proofs of Jesus and so forth there's
nothing wrong with researching those
things it's a very good thing to
research but not as an answer to doubt
if we research to cure doubt then we're
still relying on our own understanding
and were demanding proof and the doubts
will only intensify because we're
looking for answers where they cannot be
and we're looking for answers in the
wrong way instead we have to simply
bring our doubts to God humble ourselves
and say Lord I'm weak I'm frail I'm
foolish you know please strengthen my
faith I we just come to God empty-handed
with nothing and just say God I got
nothing and if we do that you know that
kind of prayer well we just come to God
in humility and submission recognizing
our own frailty our own weakness and we
come to him asking for an amount asking
for you know we're not asking for a job
promotion we're not asking to win the
lottery we're not asking for any
material benefit whatsoever
we're just saying God just give me
please give me faith give me faith so I
can glorify you all the more give me
faith so I can be more of a light to
those around me and God will always
answer that prayer they'll always answer
that
and that's really enough that doesn't
need to be specific the prayer I mean I
you know I know some Christians think
that our prayers need to be super
specific all the time god I want this I
want this I want this I want this okay
like a child making a Christmas list or
something but Jesus tells us that the
father already knows what we want before
we even ask for it so sometimes that the
purest prayer is just to take our
brokenness our doubts our pride our
whole being and bring them to God in our
hearts and then just be there in his
presence contemplating him in his
divinity and that's it that's the prayer
I know in the past that you know I have
in the past gotten two points in my life
where there's just so much fog so much
anxiety there's just this this tangle of
knots in my head and in my soul and I'm
so confused and so lost that there was a
point where I felt like you know I can't
even pray anymore because I don't even
know what to say or what where to begin
there's just you know I didn't even know
I don't know what I even need or how to
ask for it but eventually I figured out
that that God is God and he doesn't need
my explanations he doesn't need my
speeches he doesn't need me to
persuasively argue you know my case for
what I want in my prayer all he needs me
to do is just come to the cross kneel
before it and say I'm here Lord I'm here
change me although we should always be
very careful with that prayer to change
me prayer it's a dangerous prayer
because it's so effective because if you
bring that to God and you mean it he'll
do it he'll do it in ways you didn't
expect
so this is what we do with doubt and if
we get that if we get into the habit of
always bringing everything to God and
praying unceasingly he will give us a
deeper knowledge of his presence and a
deeper sense of it and we may not be
able to explain it we may not be able to
prove it he may not give us this
knowledge accompanied by brilliant
intellectual arguments so that we can
argue in favor of it although maybe he
will but for most of us he won't but
he'll still give us that knowledge a
knowledge that transcends proof and then
something really crazy happens because
you get to the point as your faith grows
because we remember that you know faith
is a is a not a stagnant thing faith is
a living breathing growing thing and as
your faith grows you get to the point
where even when you doubt you still know
even when you doubt you still believe
even when you have doubts you still have
faith that doesn't change the faith is
there because you've given yourself to
God you're holding on to him he's
holding on to you you still have that
faith and so those doubts are just
they're coming from the outside and
they're bombarding your brain but it
doesn't change the fact that you're
holding tight and we become like I think
Peter and what I think is one of the
most beautiful passages in the Gospels
and I you know I love Peter in the
Gospels I think Peter is is he's such a
great and relatable figure because he's
you know he's kind of kind of brash and
he kind of talks without without
thinking sometimes and he's obviously
he's weak you know he has he has he
betrayed Christ so he's got cowardice as
well but he's also got courage I mean
think about think about it when Jesus
was arrested before and then Peter would
turn around and deny Christ three times
but before that he lashes out with a
sword and he cuts somebody's ear off to
try to defend Christ because he loves
Christ so much he still has his weakness
as a human being but he loves him in
that moment it's just instinct like no
you're not gonna touch geez
that's what makes Peter so relatable is
that he's just human he's a human being
he's a so there's this scene in the
Gospels after Jesus tells the crowd that
he's the bread of life and whoever
consumes this bread will be saved and
the crowds hear this and they revolt and
many of his followers were told leave
him that day because they just they
cannot accept even some of these had
witnessed miracles but they cannot
accept this teaching because they just
don't understand it
and it's so far outside of their
conception of things and so they just
get up and leave and they say nope I
know no way so everyone's leaving and
then you can kind of imagine how this
plays out that just the crowd thins
everyone's leaving they're walking away
mumbling to each other I mean this is
you know saying oh this guy's crazy
that's that's nuts and they all walk
away and then Jesus turns to the twelve
who are still standing there and he says
what about you are you gonna leave too
and then Peter answers him Peter doesn't
say oh no Christ I mean we totally
understand what you were just saying
there I mean we get it okay
those other people they're just there
that you know they're too stupid to
understand but we understand we're
totally with you no he doesn't give that
kind of confident answer instead he just
says Lord where else would we go you
have the words of eternal life we know
that you're the Holy One of God where
else would we go and that was his answer
it was a simple helpless answer not an
entirely confident answer but it was an
honest one it's Peter just throwing up
his hands and saying where else am I
going to go Jesus I I'm in too deep
you're the Messiah I know that I I have
no idea what you just
said I have no idea what that means in
fact half of the stuff you say I have no
idea what any that means it sounds
pretty scary to be honest a lot of it
but um but your god I know that and so
I'm here and I think that was a very
crucial moment for the Apostles right
they're encountering this very difficult
doctrine but saying no we're staying
here
it's not a perfect journey after that
there's still doubt they're still denial
there's betrayal all of that still lays
ahead but there's also persistence in
the Apostles there's weakness there's
cowardice too but there's persistence
well they keep coming back to Christ
they keep turning back to him and I
think that's what we have to do we admit
to God I don't understand this I I can't
wrap my head around this it doesn't make
sense to me there's a part of my brain
rebelling saying this can't be true
and we just bring that to God we admit
we might as well admit it he knows
anyway what we're thinking no point
trying to hide it so you might as well
just bring it to God and say yeah you
know that's those are the thoughts going
on in my head I don't like it but it's
there and we entrust ourselves to him
and we say God I'm confused I'm
bewildered my ego is shouting these
doubts at me but where am I to go I'm
still here with you show me the way and
and I will follow you through the dark
and I think that's faith even when the
doubts appear so
anyway I hope that was an acceptable
answer well certainly a long one so I'll
leave it there have a great weekend guys